hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the somewhat impossible
markiplier quiz now I'm playing this
game because number one it's my birthday
for real this time no fooling and number
two I heard what this guy said about
this game and how he made it and how he
got other people involved in it and how
it's his first flash animation project
ever and how he's really proud of it he
says my name is Nicolas love and I've
been watching a video since amnesia and
I loved your videos ever since you're my
idol as you could say and I'm one of
your fans maybe not your biggest but I
admire your work a lot
I had to rewatch some of your videos to
get some of the information for the quiz
but it was worth it anyways I'm eighteen
as of now and I'm new to this whole
animation thing so for my first complete
flash animation I thought it turned out
pretty well I'd have to say my favorite
video of yours is when you played
bewilder house with the clown I couldn't
stop myself from laughing in class and
yes I do watch your videos in school
because I need some entertainment
anyways enjoy the game this is my way of
giving back to the community some
questions will be really easy some will
be hard and some will require thinking
outside the box and some questions
answers might not be the one you think
is the correct one this game is
dedicated to mark his fans and my loving
girlfriend my hand so thank you Nicholas
so much for making this and I want to
say that I don't think I've been
observant enough about things that are
made in the community I played like this
leadership role where I try to guide you
guys around but I it's dawned on me and
I get very self-reflective about you
know my birthday and I'm getting older
and I remember when I started and I
realized that there's so many small
things like this and the reason I didn't
find this one is because it's actually
kind of low rated and it gets lost in
the shuffle because you know things that
people make you know that's higher rated
gets up higher but I found this one and
you know I don't care that it's low
rated or anything because it's his first
project and it's rough around the edges
because it's the first thing he ever
made and I don't care about that because
he made it for me like someone took the
time to actually make something for me
and and also like the intro music is
like my old outro music
if you
it's my old outro music that I used to
do which was this thing that someone
remixed a long time ago and it's I love
it so much
it's pickles
I love this stuff I love it
god I love it I love these cool things
that people make for me I love the old
things
I love the new things I love it all and
I haven't been you know like putting it
out there for people to see because I
need to be the conduit for this stuff
that's made for me did it seem alright
so without further ado let's get into it
there you go well yeah the old me what
is Marx real name mark Team Edward
Fishbach mark Edward Fishbach Markham Oh
mark Edward fish Beethoven well if I
don't know my own name I am a sad
pathetic lump mark Edward Fishbach okay
we should never gonna be douchey with me
what did mark want to do before we
became a youtuber male stripper comedian
biomedical engineer or doctor Nigel oh
that's a surgeon simulator reference but
also I kind of wanted to be a male
stripper but I'm pretty sure I want to
be a biomedical engineer still do who is
mark's greatest hero superman the
blacksmith his dad a board booker dewitt
oh who is he who is he from
oh that sounds a little familiar was
that the evil within I think it was evil
within I'm not a person sure but my dad
is my greatest hero by far all right
woes marks first video and these your
reaction Caio this would depend oh no
wait on the on the options here okay it
would depend cuz my first channel that I
had it would have been a different
answer but on this one that you're
watching it on I believe the first one I
uploaded was the amnesia reaction
compilation though Bing alright where
did the phrase where's the blacksmith
come from his mouth TV another youtuber
or some guy in the village which would
probably be more accurate because it
started from a rampaging monster
wandering through the halls of all uses
oh man it was actually funny it's funny
how much this phrase still carries
through to this day because I was just
at VidCon and Jack while we were hanging
out would often like just reference it
for no reason going like where the bags
we're due blacksmith so I think I think
it originated from my mouths but I'm not
under present sure about that okay good
enough for me how many subscribing
milestones at mark posted videos about
well I don't know I don't know when this
video was posted it oh gosh this is the
right answer because none of the answers
at Mandi yet I want to choose that one
but 26 a [ __ ] oh god no I didn't move oh
god it fails I hurt him so bad
oh man fantastic that means that it was
the it was the the trollee one oh god
it's gonna be one of those oh [ __ ] god
damn it okay this is the right answer
because none of the answers have been D
yet Oh Inc okay what is Mark's greatest
fear zero subscribers on his channel man
a petty or manicures or mannequins
what's wrong with a good old mani-pedi
how about mannequins okay huh what
university did mark go to go bighorns
University of Phoenix University of
Pennsylvania Furman University or
Eastern Colorado University
none of these are correct none of these
are right I I went to the University of
Cincinnati are they trying to make a
joke about me going to the University of
Phoenix no [ __ ]
my god and my career here yeah oh don't
let my career it's only just begun four
years ago whatever alright hang on gotta
get back to it boink boink okay Sylvania
was it Y eastern Colorado I didn't go
there
how many parts were in marks the last of
a series I don't know I think twelve
play oh no oh God oh it's gonna be a
trolli game it's gonna be a trolli game
it's gonna be a trolli game but that's
okay I can do this it's fine I got this
everybody hold on too many to count yup
okay this mark plays games without
recording in spare time yes I'd
oh okay what game did mark fail at the
most and should play again well god damn
it I know when this game was made it was
back in the vanish era of horrible
vanish nice but why is there three
vanishes and one five nights at freddys
oh do i click on this is it a joke is it
M joke
it all for joke oh god I'm trying my
best here man I've tried my best okay
alright hang on wait you shouldn't call
up two minute count yes why why that one
I failed more advantage well I guess
technically in the number of times I've
died five nights at freddys would be
correct okay which girls I'm sorry play
through to day of amnesia to tiny box
Tim be born that was a late night drink
which is my favorite amnesia custom
story I've ever - oh God in his twitch
livestreams how much has Mark currently
donated to charity now this was not me
personally this was all of you guys and
I don't know when this was and the only
difference is the sense oh yeah okay got
it
okay alright what is market buyers dog
name oh my gosh this is before I had
chica Oh chica no don't get up it's okay
this is before hey chica this is back
when buddy oh my god buddy buddy with an
eye because buddy we thought it was a
boy then later discovered that it was a
girl sorry we weren't looking very
closely apparently yes okay where was
Mark born in Hawaii on earth in a
hospital were on a military base well
all of these are technically correct I
don't know if I was actually born on a
military base my dad was in the military
but I don't know if it was on the base
in Hawaii
whoa damn it Hospital damn it on earth
that's not smart
and apparently to the Internet that duck
is very sexy
people that took is not sexy stop it
it's not a sexy duck god damn it how do
I keep doing this I keep getting like I
keep getting up uh all three wrong on
one question and then frickin balls in
it up all over the way so on earth yeah
okay what is not one of marks impossible
Let's Plays the soda bath challenge I
don't even know what that is
okay how many videos are currently in
marks horror playlist just choose the
right answer this time
what oh god oh god okay so it means the
right answer so yes okay what are the
little kitties those are Santa elves
don't ask questions they're the Santa's
elves all right which game has it's very
own markiplier mom that was SCP oh yeah
I see P Adam markiplier mod I should
play that again Kaaba should there's
probably a lot of people out there that
are like yes play ICP again even though
I've played it like I've got like 50
episodes of it but if there's new
updates I'll definitely play it okay
who is scp-173 wouldn't that Billy Bob
that was Billy Bob huh
damnit I thought it was Billy Bob but
creeping booting voodoo doll looking
creature someone I don't want to be
around my worst nightmare all of these
could apply somewhat I don't want to be
rude yes okay did Mark cheat sometimes
while playing SCP containment breach
no you saw nothing nothing you said you
saw nothing all right
when did markiplier upload his first
drawing minecraft episode okay it would
have been 2012 I'm not a hundred percent
sure if it was the 8th or the 9th I
believe you have no idea Hey yes okay in
which episode of outlast whistleblower
did mark see something so gruesome and
horrible that he had to be reminded of
it Oh God there weren't that many
episodes of whistleblower because it was
just DLC I believe there was only five
so it was towards the end you all know
what I'm talking about right
it was pretty bad so wasn't the first
two and it wasn't the last so it must be
for yes press B to blue okay well how
does markiplier usually start his video
hello everybody my name is markiplier
ah by looking at the camera first and
then saying answer a pointing and
shouting answer a staring heavily into
your eyes I'm pretty sure pointing and
shouting whoa damn it looking in the
camera Hey okay which game did Mark
raids the most that and should play
again well god damn it okay based on the
last there's a lot of vanish here I
think people want me to play van some
people I beat vanish I finally beat
vanish but some people say I didn't
officially beat vanished because I beat
the updated version of vanish that made
it easier and that's [ __ ] I beat it
fair and square so you can't really say
I didn't surgeon simulator okay I
haven't played it in forever all right
which game did Mark have most fun with
every game except for vanish yeah that
sounds about right
okay which D mod game-mode is Mark
Clayton recorded the most of I would
believe prop hunt I'm pretty sure which
we need to play even more of Blink okay
in the first episode of Octodad dadliest
catch where was the game in the
beginning it was a wedding it was a
wedding yeah oh the DLC was in a
restaurant though Punk okay
whereas mark always wanted to go spicy I
suppose I must end my career here as I
want to go to space I don't even see
what the other answers were was there
something else that I wanted to do god
dammit bureau b where does mark want to
go then this drama which is from alien
isolation I believe or didney worl on
Dendy world I want to go to Disney World
yes okay alright how do you get famous
on YouTube let's start a let's drive
channel stranger baby makeout
circle-jerk oh my god this is from my
favorite sketch we've ever done oh man
this all seems really weird if you
haven't seen that one it's called
uh I believe it's called how to get
famous on YouTube literally the name of
the question and the answer of course is
circle jerk while kissing a baby in a
car which admittedly sounds really weird
if you haven't seen the video so watch
the video okay alright why did Mark cry
a little
oh so many reasons I was playing dred
halls yeah I was playing vanish maybe he
got something in the lie probably it was
his important message video um
just knowing your stick-on vanish dammit
I got something in my eye dammit I did I
did I did tear up a bit of drede dolls
yes okay all right what was the scariest
game in years I was five nights at
freddys December 25th what will mark
become Santa pliable know what but
that's what I would have been awed and a
god damn it hari Han on December 25th
what will mark become baby plier Wilfred
Wolf Wilfred it's Wilfred thank you full
of presents and gifts well if it's not
Santa plier that's what I do well I
actually know it's not what I do because
I haven't done it a long time then full
of presents and gifts okay yeah okay
how many times did mark failing the
original market bar quiz I don't know a
lot less than I failed in this one
probably for considering that's the most
okay yeah markiplier is king of the
squirrels I've cared of the squirrels no
god dammit
the Castle ocean YouTube I'm not the
king of YouTube no way was Mark so
fascinated with space thank you finally
you get it which episode of alien
isolation was mark so sleep-deprived I
don't know how am I to know 7 6 8 9 6 7
ok thank you
what did markiplier use the most of an
alien isolation same stations as
flamethrower noisemakers or revolver I
don't even know if there was a revolver
in the game I used a flame thrower but I
didn't have enough fuel
I actually didn't use the noisemakers
very much because I was not very
strategic in that game so I'm assuming I
save way too much okay thank you who is
the protagonist an alien isolation now
that was Ripley's daughter I believe
Ripley Junda yeah okay was there a
cutscene at the end of the credits and
alien isolation yes
maybe I believe it wasn't there
something with like actually Ripley
wasn't actually Ripley and yes
oh damn it okay no okay and evil within
what were all the names in the main
characters Booker - oh it was it was
evil within Booker DeWitt Joe Joe Kidman
Leslie and ruvik um I'm glad they put
Josh are they gonna accept my naming of
Joe Joe because I don't think Joe has
any other name but Joe Joe at this point
uh I think I know I think his name
actually was Sebastian but I kept
calling him Booker do it hey okay what
did mark call the green gel in the evil
within
I believe I call it brain goop whoa oh
damn it
uh the good stuff whoa
god damn it green goo yes okay thank you
in the final episode of evil within what
did Mark say the books were for
books are for nerds books are for nerds
I just have to remember what I'd say now
and it's pretty cute what he said then
maybe yes thank you
which game did baby plyer appear in it
and got cake that was among the sleep I
believe yes okay if Mark were to become
a teacher what subject would he teach
obviously American history because my
ability to recall events that occurred
in America is impeccable thank you
tiny box Tim is my little biscuit
when vanished what made mark jump um
well the monster the steam pipes nothing
everything I'm pretty sure everything
did because I'm a big bubble blowing
baby yes in the impossible quiz what
question did mark it wrong and failed
during his first playthrough I don't
know how am I to know I don't know I've
got no lives left any meenie miney moe
catch a tiger by the toe one calls them
go any bid by moe okay whoa
insurgent simulator which operation
embark range at the most it was the
double candy god damn it Cheers
yes so much for your support every
and you know I just sometimes have to
reflect and use that as motivation and
justification to keep moving forward
because two and a half years I've been
doing this all day every day
it's the only thing I've cared about so
far in last two and half years and it's
a big thing to care about so it's nice
to be able to keep going so I the way
that's enough rambling for me you know
you get a lot of rambling for me as a
enough as it is just seriously thank you
guys so much for everything
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye oh well thank you see see
this is why this is why I love playing
these things and there's actually two
more parts to this but I'm not gonna
play them right now because I don't have
much time in this videos already gonna
be late but it's just this is why I play
these games because they remind me you
know they remind me I've been doing this
a long time like a long time and I know
there's been people on YouTube that have
been around longer than me but that was
two and a half years and when I said
that it's almost five that's almost like
man so there's two years ago so much can
happen in so much a little time and it's
turning into so much happening so long
of a time and so I I don't care if this
game is a little rough I loved it I love
it I love it when people make me things
chicas coming over hi chica I love you I
love it you know I just love doing these
things and I love seeing like all these
amazing things I love being reminded of
the things that I played in the past I I
really do
I just really love it all and I love the
fact that it's still here and I you know
uh I've become known as the guy that you
know cries on camera and like I you'd be
shoes it's so funny how many
as I run into the patrol they ask me
about I just you know I want to I want I
want to like you know I just I'm just
you know I'm happy I'm happy to be able
to do this I'm happy to have so many
memories I'm happy to have so many
memories to look back on and I'm happy
that I'm still making more you know and
even like I'm gonna look back a few
years from now and I'm gonna look back
at this these are why places cuz these
are the moments when I could look back
and remember ah okay alright I'm gonna
get out of here before I start getting
too sappy about it but thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
so much for making this game I want to
see more I want to see more I want to
see more things that people make for me
I know there's so many and so hard to
find them nowadays cuz there's so many
so many pieces of fan art being made and
there's so much stuff you know post your
fan art to the deviant deviantART page
it's still there I'll put it in the
description like it's been there since
the beginning I've never even really
said how appreciative I am of the
moderators that run that thank you I
remember some of the oldest pieces of
fan art ah stop it okay
all right I'm gonna go ahh oh my go
alright but thank you everybody so much
for watching and thank you for being
here with me for so long and thank you
for supporting me and really get get
these games to me get these you'll get
these things to me I want to see him I
want to see them all I really do so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye